le safran se mérite à 8 heures du matin
il faut se baisser pour ramasser les
fleurs qui renferme le précieux piste il
alors chacun sa technique
accroupis pencher ou à genoux le dos on
prend un bon coup les muscles fessiers
donc de toutes façons on essaye toujours
de cueillir pendant 1h 1h30 2h grand
maximum donc on n'embauche plus de
saisonniers de façon si vraiment on a
plus de production pour avoir fini que
la cueillette ont deux heures maximum
parce que pour une heure de cueillette
il y aura trois heures d'émondage
derrière la ferme récolte généralement
deux cent cinquante mille fleurs mais
cette année la voilure est réduite
les producteurs ont embauché moitié
moins de saisonniers ils vont arrêter la
récolte plus tôt et cela à cause de la
situation sanitaire
nos clients ce sont des restaurateurs
des traiteurs des métiers de bouche et
donc ils sont très impactées par par le
cos vide au niveau du saf en tout cas où
certains saumons au niveau du safran
malgré tout la récolte se poursuit après
la cueillette l'émondage il s'agit de
séparer le pistil de la fleur c'est
trois petits filaments rouges vifs et ce
qui frappe c'est le parfum qui sont des
gages l'odeur c'est assez assez
surprenant oui ouais jamais comment
très parfumée parfois enivrante
mais plaisante une récompense pour ce
travail fastidieux c'est ensuite une
machine qui prend le relais pour l'étape
du séchage en l'espace de 24 heures le
safran perd un peu plus de 80 % de son
poids
résultat ça ne pèse pas lourd par
exemple à vous avez un gramme de safran
pour faire un gramme il faut entre 150
et 200 fleurs on vous avait à peu près
450 à 500 filaments dans ce petit bocal
et du coup avec ça on va pouvoir
aromatisés entre 80 et 120 assiette sans
problème un gramme de safran vote
environ 30 euros c'est une épice de luxe
que ce producteur vend notamment à des
restaurateurs du coin
ce chef est un habitué le plat du jour
c'est un dos de cabillaud avec ec
raismes au safran c'est vraiment un
produit concerts dans les périodes
froides en été c'est un petit peu plus
du pays qu'à mais avec les poissons ça
marche super bien les peas a aussi le
palais sucré elle se marie bien au
chocolat et rehaussent une crème brûlée
qu'on se rassure pas besoin d'en mettre
beaucoup pour avoir un plats parfumés